lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es que desarrollemos práctica tomando
oraciones como estas y escribiendo las
en lenguaje matemático que muy
probablemente va a utilizar paréntesis
así es que pues vamos a empezar y como
siempre si en cualquiera de estas
oraciones tú te sientes muy inspirado
ponle pausa al vídeo y escribe esta
oración como una expresión matemática ok
bueno vamos a empezar con esta oración
que dice 709 menos 19 dividido a la
mitad y otra forma de pensar en las
cosas cuando las estamos dividiendo a la
mitad es pensar en que las vamos a
dividir entre 2 aunque entonces vamos a
poner por aquí 709 menos 19 y como vamos
a hacer esta resta primero entonces la
vamos a poner entre paréntesis
dividido a la mitad o sea tenemos que
dividir entre dos aunque esta es otra
forma de expresar lo que tenemos aquí y
ahora vamos con esta otra oración y lo
repito si te sientes inspirado por la
pausa el vídeo ya sólo por tu cuenta
pero bueno tenemos aquí tres por la suma
de 56 y 7 aunque hay entonces esto de la
suma de 56 y 7 lo vamos a hacer primero
entonces lo vamos a poner entre
paréntesis 56 más 7 ok la suma de 50 y
67 y nosotros lo que queremos es
multiplicar 3 por la suma de 56 y 7
entonces vamos a poner por aquí
por y aquí está la suma de 56 y 7 y
bueno otra cosa que te vas a encontrar a
cada rato cuando veas paréntesis que
bueno generalmente te lo vas a encontrar
con álgebra un poco más complicada o
elevada aunque esto que estamos haciendo
aquí no tienen nada de elevado ok pero
cuando tenemos paréntesis a veces
podemos no escribir el símbolo b por ok
puedes simplemente poner el 3 en frente
de los paréntesis y aquí ya entendemos
que estás multiplicando 3 por lo que
está adentro del paréntesis cree que es
56 más 7 ok estos dos están diciendo
exactamente lo mismo ahora hay que tener
mucho cuidado aquí porque tal vez aquí
sentiste la tentación de no utilizar
paréntesis y tal vez escribiste algo así
como
por 56 más 7 ahora aquí no queda muy
claro que estés multiplicando a 3 por la
suma de 56 7 lo que hay de hecho la
forma normal de interpretar esta
expresión es que tomas primero el 3 x 56
y ya que hiciste esa multiplicación le
sumas 7 a diferencia de lo que tenemos
aquí que primero tomamos 56 más 7 y
después a lo que nos queda lo
multiplicamos por 3 monkeys son dos
cosas completamente diferentes de hecho
puedes hacer estos cálculos y vas a ver
que te van a quedar dos cosas distintas
así es que para asegurar que hacemos la
suma de 56 y 7 primero y después
multiplicamos por 3 tenemos que poner
estos paréntesis por aquí
ok bueno ahora vamos con la suma de 3
por 56
entonces aquí tenemos la suma de dos
cosas si es que tenemos una suma ponemos
por aquí el símbolo de suma y la primera
cosa que estamos sumando estrés por 56
aquí ponemos por aquí 3 por 56 y la
segunda cosa que estamos sumando es este
7 ok
7 y lo que tenemos aquí lo que nos dice
el paréntesis es que multiplicamos
primero 3 por 56 y luego a eso le vamos
a sumar 7 aunque ellos es la suma de 3
por 56 y 7 ahora no siempre necesitamos
poner un paréntesis lo que hay si
ponemos el paréntesis no importa está
súper bien sin embargo si una persona
llega y escribe 3 por 56
7 esta expresión de aquí también está
bien porque como estaba diciendo antes
por aquí siempre que tengamos una
multiplicación y una suma hacemos
primero la multiplicación y después la
suma entonces si aquí no ponemos ningún
paréntesis de todas formas primero vamos
a hacer 3 por 56 y después vamos a
sumarle 7 ok esto es algo que se llama
prioridad de las operaciones y si no lo
has visto todavía no importa lo vamos a
ver muy pronto pero bueno solo para
dejarlo claro otra vez si ponemos los
paréntesis están muy bien ahora 43 menos
la suma de 16 y 11 tenemos una resta
tenemos 43 menos
43 - y luego tenemos la suma de 16 y 11
aunque vamos a poner los paréntesis
tenemos aquí menos la suma de 16 más 11
y aquí es súper importante poner estos
paréntesis porque si no pusiéramos los
paréntesis a ver vamos a hacerlo por
aquí tenemos 43 menos 43 menos y si no
ponemos los paréntesis tenemos la suma
de 16 y 11 16 más 11 y aquí lo que
haríamos normalmente si no tenemos estos
paréntesis es tomar el 43 restarle 16 y
después a eso sumarle 11 y eso no es lo
que queremos hacer porque aquí el 11 se
está sumando mientras que aquí en
realidad el 11 es parte de lo que se
está restando y si hacemos esta
operación así nos va a quedar otro
número completamente distinto
así hacemos esto porque aquí tenemos 43
menos 16 más 11 mientras que aquí lo que
estamos diciendo es que vamos a tomar 16
más 11 y después todo eso se lo vamos a
restar a 43 ok
aquí son súper súper súper súper súper
importantes estos paréntesis bueno vamos
a hacer la pantalla un poco para arriba
tenemos aquí 10 por el cociente de 104 y
8 entonces vamos a empezar con este 10 x
10 x y luego queremos el cociente de 104
y 8 y eso lo podemos escribir como 104
entre 8 o keith y bueno como vimos al
principio de este vídeo esto también se
puede escribir así ok ponemos
simplemente el 10 y al lado entre
paréntesis 104 entre
ok podemos simplemente no poner el
símbolo de multiplicación si tenemos
aquí estos paréntesis entonces vamos con
este de aquí nos dice cuatro veces más
grande que la expresión 175 menos 58
aunque empezamos con cuatro veces más
grande que o sea tenemos que poner un 4
por y luego tenemos la expresión 175
menos 58 que la expresión 175 menos 58 y
otra vez esto también se puede escribir
así ponemos simplemente el 4 y entre
paréntesis 175 menos 58 pero eso sí
estos paréntesis no los podemos quitar
porque si los quitaremos entonces
estaríamos diciendo que queremos
multiplicar 4 por 175 y después
y restarle 58 y eso no es lo que
queremos aunque queremos multiplicar 4
por todo esto de aquí que es la resta de
175 menos 58 y vamos un poco más para
arriba porque esto de aquí acaba de
hacer que me acuerde de algo súper
interesante que por ejemplo qué tal que
llega alguna otra persona y escribe un
bonche de números por aquí por ejemplo
digamos que llega y escribe algo así
como
y bueno estoy poniendo estos números ni
siquiera los voy a decir en voz alta
pero llega una persona y escribe esto
aquí
lo multiplica por 2 y luego lo vuelve a
escribir por aquí 183 mil 576 más 37 mil
399 pero ahora lo quiere multiplicar por
7 y te dice dime rápidamente cuál de
estas dos expresiones es la más grande
y bueno tú tal vez te sientes tentado o
bueno tal vez no pero tal vez te sientes
tentado a sacar rápidamente la
calculadora o tal vez a hacerlo a mano y
sumar estos dos números 183 mil 576 más
37 mil 399 hacer la suma de estos dos
números y después multiplicarlo por 2
que te va a quedar algún número extraño
y te sientes tentado también a hacer
esta suma y multiplicarlo por 7 y te va
a dar otro número y después quieres
comparar estos dos números para ver cuál
es el más grande
no va a ser tan rápido y además es
probable que hagas algunos errores de
dedo o algo así pero algo realmente
padre aquí algo realmente útil acerca de
estas expresiones es que no necesitas
hacer estas operaciones para saber cuál
es la expresión más grande
markel porque aquí si hicieras esta suma
te quedaría algún número no sé sería
como 200.000 y cacho pero lo que nos
ayuda mucho es que en este paréntesis te
va a quedar
exactamente ese mismo número entonces si
multiplicas un número por 2 te va a
quedar un número más chico que si
multiplicas ese número por siete así es
que podemos decir rápidamente que esta
expresión es la más grande de estas dos
expresiones ok sin tener que hacer todas
estas cuentas y eso es lo padre de estas
expresiones matemáticas cuando te
preguntan cosas acerca de ellas puedes
primero observa
qué estructura tienen y tal vez
encuentres lo que estabas buscando más
fácilmente o sin tener que hacer todas
las cuentas bueno espero que disfrutes
de esto tanto como yo lo disfruté